je vous jure la vidéo des fois ça rend
complètement fou moi depuis que je suis
vidéaste je suis devenu complètement
parano sur certains trucs mais genre
voilà et salue les gens derrière l'écran
c'est françois pour la chaîne explique
moi encore je suis ravi de vous
retrouver comme à chaque fois et ça fait
hyper longtemps qu'on sait pas vu
d'ailleurs ça fait plus de trois
semaines mais j'étais juste surchargé de
boulot j'avais du taf de ouf
et justement j'ai pensé à vous pendant
que je bossais parce que il y avait des
trucs qui me stresser et je me suis dit
que j'allais partager avec vous ma
solution qui me déstresse un petit peu
et qui me permet d'être quasiment sûrs à
99,9 pour cent ne jamais perdre un seul
fichier vidéo échec vous l'avez sûrement
entendu plein de fois un fait des
sauvegardes c'est hyper important mais
c'est hyper important
ce que déjà quand on est juste amateurs
ça fait chier de perdre des fichiers
parce que bon on s'est cassé le cul à
monter un truc à faire une vidéo on les
perd ça fait chier mais en plus quand on
est pro à bas juste c'est indispensable
d'avoir plein de rempart de sécurité
pour pas perdre ces fichiers parce que
tu peux pas aller voir ton client et lui
dire je suis désolé j'ai perdu vos
fichiers votre vidéo elle est foutue
c'est juste pas possible tu peux pas
faire ça tu es griller dans le milieu
après c'est impossible et on entend ce
genre de truc arriver quand même assez
souvent
donc c'est finalement les gens entendent
pas le truc de la sauvegarde
alors vous allez me dire bah elle je
prends un disque dur tu fais une copie
terminé on va dire que c'est un début
mais il faut quand même aller vachement
plus loin parce que ce qu'il faut garder
en tête c'est que aucun matériel est
infaillible et le pas de bol un des
trucs qui pète à répétition ça arrive à
tout le monde donc je vous donnais
plusieurs astuces qui vont vous
permettre de sécuriser vos données et
d'être quasiment sûrs que ça
fonctionnera tout le temps que vous
allez rien perdre qu'il faudrait une
catastrophe nucléaire où un truc
douce mais que le petit pas de bol ne
pourra pas arriver
je vais donc vous expliquer maurer flow
première chose c'est le double slot sd
dans votre boîtier la salle à c'est pour
mettre deux cartes sd alors le double
slot sd c'était dans mon cahier des
charges quand j'ai acheté mon boitier
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles
j'ai pris un sony à 7,3 et ce double
slot sd on peut l'utiliser de plusieurs
façons la première façon c'est de ne
mettre qu'une carte sd 1 ça fonctionne
très bien si on n'a qu'une seule mais
dans la mesure où il y en a 2 je vois
pas trop l'intérêt de ne pas utiliser
cette fonctionnalité
même pour des photos de vacances ou
voilà je vois pas l'intérêt la deuxième
possibilité c'est d'utiliser ces cartes
sd en cumulant le stockage des deux
mains pour avoir plus de stockage
mais là encore je vois pas trop
l'intérêt dans la mesure où on peut
acheter des cartes sd à 128 giga donc
techniquement il ya pas mal de places
sauf si vraiment on fait un truc de
malade et enfin la troisième possibilité
celle que moi j'utilise c'est la
possibilité de créer une carte miroir
sur laquelle en fait vont se copier
toutes les données de la carte
principale comme ça si une des deux
cartes sd fois ce qui peut arriver mais
on aura tous les fichiers conserver sur
l'autre carte sd et pour que les deux
claques en même temps il faudrait
vraiment un gros coup de pot de bol ça
c'est notre premier rempart contre la
perte de données et au delà sages ne
formate mes cartes sd qu'à la toute fin
du procès ce camp la vidéo elle est
terminée elle est validée et que bagis
je sais que là je peux supprimer cette
sécurité mais je ne fais pas avant la
deuxième étape c'est quand je rentre
chez moi après un shooting la première
chose que je fais c'est de vider mes
cartes sd sur mon système en raid genre
pas le lendemain pas droit jours après
90 je rentre je vide mes cartes ou si je
suis en extérieur j'en fais une copie
sur un disque directement pourquoi parce
que ben potentiellement si je le fais
pas le jour même le lendemain je peux
oublier je peux prendre mon appareil
photo et me dire tiens
je vais faire de la place sur ma carte
je formate est en fait bénéficier j'ai
terminé ma claque et le système en raid
justement je vous en avais parlé très
rapidement dans la vidéo sur le set up
on va aller un petit peu plus loin là
aujourd'hui ce système en raid c'est un
lacis to big doc qui m'a gentiment était
envoyé par la cie donc je les remercie
et c'est un boîtier qui va comporter
deux disques durs de d'itéra chacun à
vous allez me dire mais en quoi est ce
que serait dit les plus sécurisés qu'un
disque dur classique
je vous explique un système en raid avec
deux disques on peut l'utiliser de deux
façons différentes en raid 0 et en raid
1 en raid0 on va en quelque sorte
cumuler les deux disent qu'on va avoir
un seul volume de reconnus par leur dit
qu'il va être de 21-10 +10 et on va
cumuler les performances de chaque
disque ce qui fait qu'on va se retrouver
avec un disque dur qui va avoir des
performances avoisinant un petit peu
celle des ssd ssd pas trop rapide on est
bien d'accord et je pourrais très bien
faire du montage directement là dessus
c'est assez rapide pour pour gérer ça
mais le problème c'est que s'il ya un
des disques qui claquent tout lac donc
pas cool et donc ça veut dire que niveau
sécurité c'est pas ouf
mais il ya aussi la possibilité
d'utiliser ce système en raid 1
et là on va avoir chaque disque qui va
se copier l'un l'autre en permanence qui
peut comme les cartes sd dans le boîtier
voyez le et si l'un des disques flash
et bien tout simplement on l'enlève on
en met un autre et les fichiers vont se
recopier d'eux mêmes directement sur le
disque ne en gros ce raid on va dire
c'est une sauvegarde tampon temporaire
parce qu'il faut dire aussi qu'un raid 1
c'est pas non plus le graal en termes de
sécurité un l'idéal c'est quand même un
raid 5
en plus de ça cela site mobile il a deux
petits trucs assez sympa il a un lecteur
de cartes directement intégrés et un
port usb 3 qui fait que je prends ma
carte sd je la mets dans le lecteur je
copie mes fichiers dessus directement
quand je rentre un tel suivi et on a
encore une sécurité supplémentaire on a
un second rempart contre la perte et
rush qui nous amène à la troisième étape
du workflow ce sont les ssd comme le
raid ne propose pas des performances
assez importante pour que je puisse
monter directement dessus je monte sur
des disques ssd je ne monte pas en
interne même si mon imac un disque dur
qui envoie sa race parce que j'ai
parfois des projets qui sont très très
gros et qui prendrait beau
ou trop de place donc je préfère bosser
en externe et puis si je suis amené à
travailler sur un autre ordi en
déplacement il suffit de prendre le
disque dur est de travailler directement
dessus et sur ses ssd je mets une
troisième copie de mes fichiers et ma
bibliothèque final cut puisque j'utilise
une bibliothèque par projet comme ça
c'est plus facile à classer plus facile
archers et bien entendu je fais
régulièrement des copies de la
bibliothèque qui se trouve sur le ssd
vers leur aide alors toutes les deux
trois heures quand je fais des grosses
sessions de montage pour que si le ssd
venait à lâcher je perde pas tout le
table de montage que j'ai fait alors
question ssd externes j'en ai plusieurs
en fonction des projets
mais ce que je kiffe vraiment c'est ce
que je vous mets dans la description cd
samsung ils sont tout petits ils sont
assez rapides quand même ils permettent
vraiment de monter tranquillement la 4k
ça passe crème fire vraiment aucun souci
et ils sont pas très cher un on trouve
par exemple un terrain de ssd pour 120
ou 130 euros des fois ya des promos donc
c'est encore moins cher donc là dessus
sont vraiment cool pas grand chose de
plus à dire dessus
si ce n'est que monter en externe
utilisé ça mange pas de pain enfin la
quatrième et dernière étape de
sauvegarde tout ça c'est l'archivage
pour ça je pense que j'ai opté pour un
dock des disques de 3 pouces et demi et
qui de bois boîte pour les ranger pour
les archiver parce que les rushes les
plans les montages j'en aurais peut-être
besoin par la suite que ce soit pour un
client que ce soit pour faire un best of
ou réutiliser des plans parce que j'en
aurai peut-être besoin
et puis ça me permettra de vider petit à
petit leur aide même si avec lady terra
j'ai de la marge voilà les amis c'était
ma solution pour se déstresser un petit
peu au niveau des sauvegardes 1 quand on
applique un process de ce type
franchement on se soulagent un petit peu
l'esprit on se dit qu'on va pas perdre
tout le taf qu'on a fait et puis surtout
on risque pas de passer pour un guignol
en disant qu'on a perdu les fichiers
sachez également qu'il existe plein
d'autres façons de faire un qu'il existe
plein d'autres matériels d'ailleurs mais
témoin dans les commentaires les
solutions de sauvegarde que vous vous
utilisez pas ce que ça peu être hyper
est intéressant de voir entre nous les
solutions que peuvent avoir les uns et
les autres pour se simplifier la vie et
être encore plus sûr de ne rien perdre
et puis maintenant vous avez l'habitude
ainsi cette vidéo vous a plu n'hésitez
pas à mettre le traditionnel coup de
plaster ce le pouce en l'air qui se
situe juste en dessous de cette vidéo
pouvez également vous abonner si ce
n'est pas déjà fait partager commenter
laïque et tous à faire du bruit
moi je vous dis surtout rester curieux
et à très bientôt pour une prochaine
vidéo
alors les semaines qui viennent je
garantis pas la vidéo par semaine là je
un moment j'étais quand même proche du
zombie dans les semaines qui se sont
écoulées et je crois que les semaines à
venir ça va être chaud patate de chez
chaud patate mais je vous oublie pas et
j'essaie de vous faire des vidéos le
plus souvent possible indique mois s'il
ya des choses que vous voulez dans les
commentaires je vous dis à très bientôt
car sur vous les amis merci d'être là
merci de rester jusqu'à la fin